can you flip the script with a little
snip snip it might be the greatest idea
in history reversible vasectomies as a
new form of male birth control in a
recent recent article in the spectator
which is the magazine and not the guy
outside my bathroom window
writer guy shepard argues that with roe
v wade out women will be asking more of
men in the family planning department so
he urges dudes to freeze their sperm
then get reversible vasectomies younger
in life before kids
quote the best birth control plan for a
young man and society is for him to
harvest his youngest and best swimmers
as early as possible put him in a
freezer under lock and key and then get
a vasectomy the end no unwanted
pregnancy no need for road abortion
fewer deadbeat dads vd maybe
baby never
bd what is that vin diesel
yes
and what's vin diesel the serial number
of a truck
but it makes sense and sounds like a
win-win for everyone the writer claims
this could be even more transformative
than the pill itself plus think of all
the kids who won't have to be told they
were an accident anymore i always hated
that
i just hope
i just hope the freezers are on a
generator accidental thawing leaves you
with spoiled rotten kids
[Laughter]
and if you store them in your own fridge
just be sure they're away from the
caviar
funny i'm gonna end there
tyrus
if i were a parent right now
i did i would force my son to do this
like the moment
he's born
vasectomy now
i'm going to take my 10 year old in next
week
how i just is there is there a time
machine that could possibly yeah
this is a great idea the the problem is
we're going it's going to affect uh a
lot of tv shows
because there'll be no more teens so
you're going to be upset there'll be
more teen wives and basketball wives is
done
like there's gonna be so many happy
professional athletes out there just
living their best life
oh man if i could turn back the clock i
would have got the permanent one and
lyden said it was reversible
thank god your kids don't watch
i think
no
[Laughter]
but i just this is a great idea it's
just you know
i just hope this wasn't this technology
hasn't been around for a while because
i'm gonna i wanna sue because i've been
besmirched
[Laughter]
emily good idea
totally sure what i thought was so weird
about this guy's whole persuasive
argument is he said
that for this to happen that the
difference will depend on women men are
not organized women are without our
leadership he says then this will never
happen so the whole point of that this
argument is he was saying like women you
need to rise up and force the men to do
this moms you need to fork over your
credit card for your sons to do this and
i felt a little bit like yeah men are
not you do you women
i routinely lose just one shoe yeah
there you go see
why this is true this is i agree with
this this is true we won't we won't do
it so we need to be pushed we won't do
it until we have one
once we have that first child and
divorce left or whatever
then we'll be along we'll be in the line
like this
no men men won't do it because they like
the way things are now where it's all up
to the woman to do everything and if
anything happens you get to go she trap
me she's crazy
that's what they do
you know what i'm not talking about
leslie what do you think of this idea i
kind of see an employment opportunity
that's true is it too late for us to
learn how to do i can volunteer you know
at the vasectomy
clinics and do the assessment
[Laughter]
because there's different kinds just put
it out let me see it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no i think it'd be great i just don't i
don't think they would ever do it like
there was there was like a male birth
control being studied and then the study
was stopped because there were side
effects
which definitely doesn't happen with
women's birth control
it does by the way
i just think that it reduces so many
risk factors it would be great but i
just don't see anyone most men doing
well we're just starting to talk about
it now what if there's a ground swell of
support right yeah i'll get it i'll get
a tattoo of it on my cheek
get it done fellas wait till you're
established you know
it's a little expensive that's the other
thing i mean it's it's what 650 or
something that's what they are yeah kids
are at least 800.
let me see if i can yeah emily yeah
650.
18 years under a bus with an evil person
yelling at you where's my check where's
my check
you send the check
you should be the ambassador for this
you should be the spokesman
and you could be the nurse
you'd be the greatest nurse ever
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else